[Musik]
das da das ist seit heute Geschichte in
allen Bussen und Bahnen überall in
Deutschland die Regierung die kann sich
aber trotzdem warm anziehen vergessen
und Verzeihen viele können und wollen es
nicht die Politik muss ich auf eine
große Klagewelle einstellen es gibt viel
zu besprechen heute hier bei 8:15 Uhr
mit Ökonomen und Autor Mark Friedrich er
sorgt sich um das Bargeld und mehr noch
wir alle werden zum gläsernen Menschen
und verlieren so lieb gewonnene
Freiheiten sagt er mein Kollege
bildpolitikreporter Sebastian Geißler
ist entsetzt über eine
Stellenausschreibung Wirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck sucht externe Juristen für
schlappe 20 Millionen Euro er wird sie
vielleicht bewerben wir werden ihn
fragen Rechtsanwältin Hoffmann Feuer ist
aber noch schwer beschäftigt denn er
bereitet gerade eine Corona Sammelklage
gegen den Start vor mit Zukunftsforscher
interessantes werfen wir einen Blick in
die Zukunft und die sieht vollkommene
Generationen nicht unbedingt gut aus
wenn jetzt nicht hart umgesteuert wird
sagte er ja jetzt auch in Deutschland
ich habe gerade schon gesagt seit
Mitternacht ist die Maske Geschichte in
Deutschland jedenfalls in Bussen und
Bahnen viele Bürger atmen erleichtert
auf wer will kann sie natürlich auch
weitertragen was Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach ja auch empfiehlt schon lange
aber es umstritten wie sinnvoll die
Maske je war eine aktuelle Studie jetzt
gezeigt der Nutzen war wohl eher gering
vor allem weil die Maske aber auch eines
Symbol Vorsicht wir haben eine schwere
Pandemie ja Herr Friedrich das Ende der
maskenpflicht ist das längst überfällig
oder halten Sie das womöglich für
gefährlich nein um Gottes Willen es ist
mehr als überfällig keine konnte ja
jemand erklären warum man jetzt zwischen
Schweiz und Deutschland z.B im Zug noch
Maske tragen musste dann wieder nicht
wenn man in Niederlande gefahren ist und
es war mehr als überfällig also was ist
der Unterschied zwischen dem dem dem dem
zweiten februar und dem 7 April liegt
dann das Coronavirus irgendwie die Füße
auf dem Tisch und sagt so das war's also
es ist eigentlich nur noch macht
Geplänkel und transalieren der Bürger
der Freiheitsrechte es macht überhaupt
gar keinen Sinn mehr vor allem die
Zahlen sprechen ja ganz deutlich dass
die in ein bisschen zurückgehen ich
denke mal die Politik wollte noch mit
einigermaßen erhobenen Haupt irgendwie
aus dem ganzen Schlamassel rauskommen
wir sehen ja auch die Ratten verlassen
des Sinken des Schiff Drosten oder auch
Herr Wähler und dahingehend mehr als
überfällig und ich habe heute im Zug
habe ich es auch gehört die Leute haben
dann uploaddiert als der Schaffner
gesagt hat so ab heute keine
maskenpflicht mehr sie können Sie gerne
abnehmen die Leute waren einfach freudig
und ich habe weniger als 10% der
Menschen gesehen mit Maske und glauben
Sie denn trotzdem wird ja auch weiterhin
gewarnt weiterhin die Maske empfohlen
haben Sie das Gefühl dass man fast
versucht die Pandemie noch so ein
bisschen künstlich zu verlängern oder
warum gibt es diese Warnungen und
Warnungen noch ja man möchte wohl
versuchen mit mit rauszukommen aus der
ganzen Geschichte aber Fakt ist ja auch
es ist völlig Evidenz befreit ne also
wir wurden einfach ja auf gut deutsch ja
verarscht muss man schon fast sagen
letzten Jahre und jetzt kommt ja für die
Wahrheit ans Licht und man möchte
natürlich nicht dass die Menschen dann
irgendwann auf die Straße gehen oder
rebellieren aber es müssen Konsequenzen
folgen also einer Lauterbach sollte
schon längst mal den Hut nehmen oder die
Maske lieber und dann gleich gehen und
natürlich sich auch die Herr Drosten
Herr wiele und so weiter und die Bürger
fühlen sich auf euer veräppelt muss man
ganz klar sagen dass wir hier als einer
der letzten Bastionen eigentlich
geistiger Amokfahrer waren und versucht
haben das am Leben zu erhalten und ich
glaube bei Lauterbach geht es auch um
die politische Karriere tatsächlich sie
was sind trägst du weiter noch Maske
freiwillig in gewissen Situationen
[Gelächter]
sogar passiert da hatte ich aus Versehen
zwei Masken auf da hatte ich irgendwie
eine Aufgabe aus dem Bus nachdem wie
eine zweite maßgeblich
genau durcheinander damit das ist
Wahnsinn ähm was passiert die Maske hat
aber auch muss man ja auch mal sagen uns
ein Stück weit die Maske vom Gesicht
gerissen in andere Hinsicht immer das
Bild erlaubt ist wenn ich höre das
schaffe das z.B Kinder eine 12-jährige
irgendwie aus dem aus dem
Regionalexpress werfen irgendwo eine
Milchkanne quasi weil die irgendwie
nicht die richtige Maske dabei hatte
oder so da werden Menschen gefährdet
worden da sieht man ähm wie Menschen
sich dazu sehr billigen Vollstreckern
machen von Regeln die mindestens mal
sehr fragwürdig sind das fand ich
erschreckend aber auch eine interessante
Erkenntnis über unsere Mitmenschen wie
man hier so ticken Herz wie geht es
ihnen da erzählen sie sich eher zum Team
Vorsicht ab und zu noch die Maske an
also ich lebe ja in Wien und das ist
glaube ich mittlerweile die einzige
Stadt wo man im öffentlichen Nahverkehr
noch Masken tragen muss und das ist
mittlerweile auch schon eine muss man
sagen ein bisschen perverse Situationen
wenn man über die Landesgrenze quasi
fährt muss man sie dann anziehen oder
eben auch abziehen
also ganz klar jetzt auch mal in
Richtung Zukunft blicken muss man sagen
es ist jetzt indem ich es ist jetzt
vorbei jetzt ist die Phase der
Aufarbeitung und natürlich also man
kennt es aus dem asiatischen Raum da
tragen schon ein paar Menschen manchmal
Masken ja zum Thema kann Einrichtung und
so weiter wenn es notwendig ist dann sei
es so ich glaube es geht eher um die
symbolträchtigkeit und gar nicht mehr so
sehr wirklich um das virologische in der
ganzen Frage und diese symbolträtigkeit
im Bus und Bahn ist jetzt auf jeden Fall
schon einmal weg welche anderen
Maßnahmen können aus ihrer Sicht herr
Hofmann denn noch sofort beendet es gibt
ja noch einige beispielsweise
Impfpflicht für die Bundeswehr z.B aber
auch weiterhin massenpflicht natürlich
wenn man Krankenhäuser betritt gibt es
aus ihrer Sicht etwas von dem man sich
verabschieden sollte also das was ich ja
jetzt abzeichnet ist das für die
allermeisten Maßnahmen sowieso nie
irgendeine Form von wissenschaftlicher
vidence bestanden hat man versucht sich
ja jetzt raus zu reden in dem Sinne von
ja mit das würden wir heute nicht mehr
so machen das ist einfach nicht die
Frage die Frage ist ob man es damals
hätte schon wissen können wissen müssen
oder es möglicherweise auch gewusst hat
was man da eigentlich macht
Impfpflicht ist noch mal noch mal ein
Thema für sich wenn ich mir allerdings
anschaue vorsichtig formuliert dass wir
in Deutschland eine bisher nicht
erklärte Übersterblichkeit im Bereich
von 20 Prozent haben die wir in
zweieinhalb Jahren Pandemie nicht hatten
und keiner anfängt Fragen zu stellen wo
die herkommt sondern alle möglichen
Reserve Erklärungen aus dem Hut
gezaubert werden was habe ich neulich
gelesen in Japan sagt das
Gesundheitsministerium die Leute sterben
an
herz-id vor allem wenn wir auf die
letzten drei Jahre blicken wir sagen
jetzt heute ist zumindest der Zeit dass
die Maske fällt aber es war für ganz
ganz viele brutal Menschen sind einsam
gestorben dürften ihre Verwandten nicht
mehr sehen in ihren letzten Stunden
Kinder saßen allein und isoliert zu
Hause hat niemanden mit dem sie spielen
dürfen konnten die Schulen nicht
besuchen Existenzen gingen zugrunde das
alles sind die Konsequenzen für ganz
ganz viele Menschen und genau mit diesen
Menschen beschäftigen Sie sich jetzt da
sind wir auch direkt drin in ihrem Thema
ich möchte dazu noch einen Satz sagen
Karl Lauterbach hat heute gesagt ja
diese drakonischen Maßnahmen über die
wir jetzt auch gerade gesprochen haben
also ausgehverbote Masken tragen an der
freien Luft Kinderspielplätze draußen
absperren das sind Dinge gewesen die
würde man heute nicht mehr machen das
geht ihnen nicht weit genug das ist auch
keine Entschuldigung das geht aber auch
ganz vielen Menschen die brutal gelitten
haben nicht weit genug und genau um
diese Menschen können Sie sich jetzt mit
einer Sammelklage erklären Sie uns
einmal was es damit auf sich hat und was
Sie erreichen wollen Ihre Kamera
Sammelklage ist ja das ist ja das
falsche Wort sowas haben wir in
Deutschland nicht und das ist auch
erstmal nicht nicht der Punkt wir haben
ja was ja vollkommen richtig gerade
angesprochen wurde gesehen dass das
vollkommen aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist
der wie man ja auch in dem Einspieler
sieht dass er da laufen Leute im Schnee
mit einer Maske durch die Gegend und und
wollen Kinder dafür bestrafen dass er
ohne Maske auf dem Schlitten in der
Gegend rumfahren und dass das zu dem
Zeitpunkt keinem not vorgekommen ist
sondern dass alle brav mitgemacht haben
dass der springende Punkt jetzt stellen
sich die die führenden gestalten hin so
sie sich dann überhaupt noch hinstellen
Herr Drosten hat sich ja aus der
Gutachterkommission für die Evaluierung
der Maßnahmen Hoschi wuschi einfach
zurückgezogen er wollte da nichts mehr
mit zu tun haben Herr Wieler will mit
dem RKI nichts mehr zu tun haben und der
Gesundheitsminister der das alles nicht
nur getragen hat sondern ins lauteste
größte Horn gestoßen hat sagt jetzt na
das würden wir heute also das waren ja
drakonische Maßnahmen das waren auch
damals schon drakonische Maßnahmen und
das ist auch von einem erheblichen Teil
der Bevölkerung aus der Wissenschaft
auch von den Juristen alles mögliche
angesprochen worden und man das muss ja
auch sagen öffentlich diffamiert und
angefeindet und sonst irgendwas wurden
die Medien haben sich da auch nicht
unbedingt mit rumkleckert so dass wir im
zunehmend Leute erleben die sagen ähm
wie wollen wir das eigentlich auch
Arbeiten politisch
bin ich
skeptisch dass das passieren wird dass
da jemand von alleine Konsequenzen
ziehen wird gesellschaftlich ist der
Aufarbeitungsprozess ich glaube das ist
natürlicher Prozess der stattfinden wird
und den man glaube ich auch im
juristisch anschieben muss wir haben mit
dem Marcel lute da ja auch schon ein
paar Mal hier war der hat ja eine
Gewerkschaft gegründet und der bietet
seinen Gewerkschaftsmitgliedern an dass
wir evaluieren können wir
Schadensersatzklagen gegen den Staat
führen für Betriebsschließungen dafür
dass Leute insbesondere Kinder
psychische Störungen entwickelt haben
auch etwas was aus Richtung der der
pädiatischen Medizin wenn man denn
hingehört hätte noch lauter hätte man es
nicht schreien können das genau das
passieren wird wir haben die auf einmal
die Kinderstationen voll mit
Atemwegserkrankungen bei Kindern was für
zweieinhalb Jahren nicht hatten auch das
ist prognostiziert worden wenn man den
Kindern nicht ermöglicht ich sag mal den
Ring Tausch unter den Ansteckungen
durchzuführen dass die sich dann eine
Welle aufbaut die sich gewaschen hat
heute ist veröffentlicht worden oh wir
müssen mit einer einem Anstieg von
Krebsfällen rechnen weil die Leute sind
nicht zur Vorsorge gehen konnten da
wartet erwartet uns auch etwas und will
all diese Leute auch Leute die
wirtschaftlich ruiniert worden sind
möchten wir erreichen dass da eine
juristische Aufarbeitung stattfindet und
das eben diese Tatsache mal auch auf den
Tisch kommen weil wir da Überzeugung
sind wie gesagt das hätte man nicht nur
wissen können man hätte es wissen müssen
und man hat es in vielen Bereichen so
unsere Überzeugung auch gewusst weil
wenn man sich mal genau anschaut wer
erzählt hat das Masken was bringen dass
die Impfung was bringen Abstand halten
Lockdown alles das sind immer nur Leute
die unmittelbar oder mittelbar vom Staat
abhängig gewesen sind und von ihm Geld
bekommen haben und außerhalb außerhalb
dieser Sphäre hat sich ein viel
differenzierteres Meinungsbild
gezeichnet das gibt ja jetzt sogar der
der Gesundheitsminister dazu dass das so
ist und wir wollen erreichen dass wir
diese Fakten vor einem Gericht auf den
Tisch bringen Beweisverfahren
durchführen und dann auf der Grundlage
entscheidend ist hier nicht nur ich sag
mal verfassungswidrig gehandelt worden
sondern wenigstens fahrlässig
verfassungswidrig gehandelt worden
sprich ernsthaftung und
staatshaftungsansprüche direkt gegen den
Strom
zusammenkommen was sind das für
Geschichten die sie auch dort erfahren
für Schicksale die sie dort erfahren und
was wollen Sie erreichen also für uns
alle nicht Juristen was kann man da
erreichen hohe Geldstrafen oder was
stellen Sie vor in erster Linie
natürlich Schadensersatzzahlungen vom
vom Staat an den Bürgern
es gibt aber natürlich auch um ich sag
mal eine gewisse Form von Genugtuung für
die Leute dass das Geld ist für die
Leute tatsächlich an der Stelle sekundär
das ist auch das was was zu nehmen uns
herangetragen wird das sind Leute die
zum Beispiel diffamiert worden sind
Leute die die aus gesundheitlichen
Gründen nicht haben impfen lassen können
wo wo halt wirklich alle Ärzte gesagt
haben geht nicht Leute die aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen keine Maske
tragen konnten Leute die den der der
Laden zugemacht wurde und die von den
vor ihrem Ruin steht stehen und die sich
dann hat auch noch dafür beleidigen
lassen müssen dass sie gegen den
Anführungszeichen die corona-maßnahmen
gegen corona-politik gewesen sind und
das die wollen sich eben nicht abspeisen
lassen mit auch entschuldigung das haben
wir alles nicht gewusst
man muss eben auch die die Frage
beantworten können und diese Frage kann
politisch kann aber Antworten wenn man
es nicht hätte wissen können warum gab
es dann Leute die es gewusst haben ganz
präzise voraus haben voraussagen können
wie sich das entwickeln wird was
passieren wird und welche Schäden
dadurch eintreten dass das quasi von
Stunde Null was kann das im Einzelfall
bedeuten das klingt irgendwie wenn man
es versucht zusammenzufassen und zu
bündelnder strafen in Milliardenhöhe bis
zum Teil was können Sie das greifbar
machen natürlich sind die sind die
Schäden die da angerichtet worden sind
wenn man es mal aufsummieren wollte
tatsächlich in der in der Größenordnung
wir gehen nicht davon aus dass so viele
Leute tatsächlich in Anführungszeichen
sich juristisch so sehr dagegen wehren
wollen dass der Staat dann dass der
Staat dann Milliarden und aber
Milliarden zahlen muss an dem Schritt
sind wir auch noch nicht wir wollen plus
eine Möglichkeit haben für die Leute die
sagen ich möchte das jetzt ich möchte
jetzt wissen
Beweisverfahren durchzuführen also als
als Vorstufe von der eigentlichen
schadensersatzlage wo man sich eben vorm
Gericht trifft und sagt so wir holen
jetzt erstmal die Fakten auf dem Tisch
und Sachverständige die uns Gutachten
dazu erstellen die uns dann sagen können
was hat man gewusst was hätte man wissen
können und was hätte man wissen müssen
was ist eigentlich der wissenschaftliche
Status Quo weil das möchte ich noch mal
noch mal deutlich machen weil ja auch
Asien angesprochen wurde wir wissen von
dort was machst du tragen bringt nämlich
jemanden Community Setting gar nichts
wenn die Leute in der in der Bahn oder
am Arbeitsplatz oder so eine Maske
tragen dann das hat überhaupt überhaupt
keinen Effekt Krankenhaus andere
Geschichte wo die wo die Leute trainiert
sind eine Maske zu tragen dass sie
abschließend sitzt aber wenn ich mir
anschaue dass die Leute die Maske in die
Tasche gesteckt haben und wieder
rausgeholt haben und aufgesetzt haben
die Maske
Friedrich der Anschlag schließen wollen
Sie Antworten auf diese Frage absolut
also die Politik ist uns eine Antwort
schuldig ich muss dich entschuldigen wir
müssen auch die Gräten zwischen den
Menschen mit der schließen und Brücken
bauen die Kollateralschäden die in den
letzten drei Jahren geschehen sind sind
die gigantisch und ich glaube das ist
fast so wie oft in West damals also
wirklich die Diffamierung die
Stigmatisierung Menschen haben ihre
Existenz verloren Kinder haben keine
Bildung genießen können und so weiter
sind Billionen wahrscheinlich und wir
wurden wirklich sind das nicht geführt
wurden angelogen Twitter Fall bewiesen
das Pfeife direkt auch Leute die cancelt
hat auf Twitter das bei uns hat gesagt
wir müssen die Kritiker rausnehmen es
ist ein Ding und wie gesagt Lauterbach
muss eigentlich der Faktor zurücktreten
brauchen Entschuldigung um hier bitte
zusammenzukommen als Gesellschaft was
hier passiert ist ist eigentlich der
größte Skandal der des neuen
jahrtausendsten Twitter falls vieles
wird aber gar nicht sozusagen in Geld
messbar sein oder auf zu wiegen sein es
ist natürlich unmöglicher Hawks was
bedeutet das vor allem für junge
Menschen auch für Jugendliche Menschen
auch in Österreich waren die Maßnahmen
besonders hart da hat man eine Strafe
beispielsweise bekommen wenn man Sport
im Park gemacht hat mit mehr als zwei
oder drei Personen dann gab es eine
Geldstrafe und so was bedeutet das für
eine ganze junge Generation die Jahre so
verbringen musste zu der ersten Studien
rausgekommen dass man immer geschaut hat
wie geht's den Menschen psychologisch
jetzt danach und es scheint so als wären
bei den meisten keine bleibenden Schäden
entstanden nur bei der jüngeren
Generation bei der Generation zählt also
die die genau in diesem Alter wo man
vielleicht ein bisschen abkoppelt vom
Elternhaus versucht die Welt zu erkunden
auch Selbstwirksamkeit zum ersten Mal
erfährt genau zu dem Alter wurde das
gekappt ja und die brauchen jetzt Hilfe
das muss man schlicht und ergreifen zu
sagen also die sind natürlich jetzt
einerseits in den sozialen Fähigkeiten
ein bisschen gehemmt und andererseits
haben sie natürlich das zentrale
Erlebnis des Erwachsenen werdens genau
in diesem Übergang haben Maturaball also
Abschluss der Schule und so weiter das
haben die alles verpasst das sind
natürlich wichtige Entwicklungsschritte
und dem muss man jetzt unter die Arme
greifen ja die haben ja aufgrund von
vielen verschiedenen Dynamiken
Demografie Einkommen wo ich sonst
Verteilung und so weiter sowieso schon
relativ schwierige Karten und jetzt noch
das oben drauf ist natürlich sehr sehr
belastend und da ist davon auszugehen
dass man den wirklich auch
psychologische Hilfe bieten werden muss
weil die nächste Generation trägt
natürlich die Wirtschaft Deutschlands
und sie nehmen aber da die Politik eher
aus der Verantwortung wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe weil der so ein
bisschen Unterstützung muss kommen aber
sie haben nicht die harten drängenden
Fragen
die Frage wer gesteht sich da die
Verantwortung auch ein wer zieht
Konsequenzen beispielsweise Politik ist
zu langsam das ist das Problem keine
Erwartungen ich bin halt da nicht so
nicht verblendet also meines Erachtens
war das einzige wirklich Positive an der
Pandemie war die Zivilgesellschaft nicht
die Politik und da muss man auch Stärken
spielen und nicht auf Schwächen aber da
haben wir ja auch erschreckende
Beispiele gesehen also ich meine ich
habe mich immer gefragt wie konnte
eigentlich Hitler an die Macht kommen
jetzt muss ich sagen durch letzten drei
Jahre habe ich es gesehen und was auch
gar nicht angesprochen wurde wobei was
Sie angesprochen haben die
Übersterblichkeit wo kommt die auf
einmal her und können Medizin sie haben
32 % übersterblich gehabt im letzten
Dezemberwoche in in in Großbritannien
sind 11% vor allem auch bei jungen
Frauen also es ist ein Katastrophe wo
ist es dir Impfung da muss man Obduktion
durchführen ist es Corona Corona ist es
anscheinend nicht weil beim kommen noch
inzidenzzahlen und diese
Übersterblichkeit macht mir große Sorgen
wenn wir jetzt 32 % Übersterblichkeit
hatten in der letzten Dezember Woche in
Deutschland und die Zahlen letztes Jahr
waren bei über 20%, also wir haben hier
eigentlich nicht getesteten Impfstoff
auf die Menschheit losgelassenes Wien
Experiment gewesen und wir waren die
Kaninchen macht ihnen das Angst diese
Übersterblichkeit auch beispielsweise
Kubicki aus der FDP hat gefordert man
müsste mehr Obduktionen durchführen bei
Menschen die in einem Zeitraum nach der
Impfung gestorben sind dafür bekannt
dass Deutschland sehr wenig Obduktion
macht das muss man sagen das sind die
Österreicher ein bisschen weiter vorne
grundsätzlich ist es aber so man merkt
schon ich bin kein Mediziner es gibt da
doch auch sehr intelligente Menschen mit
medizinische Bildung die das Aufarbeiten
werden ja also wir sind ja auch bei
ihrem Beispiel die Aufarbeitung wird es
die große Frage sein ich würde mir nicht
anmaßen erklären zu wollen weswegen die
Übersterblichkeit stattfindet das wird
garantiert ein multifaktor ist System
oder eine multifaktoriellen Grund haben
und so früh schon und mit dem Finger zu
zeigen und zu sagen daran muss ich
liegen das treibt die Diskussion
natürlich weg von einer ergebnisoffen in
einer Ergebnis geschlossene Diskussion
und dann kommen wahrscheinlich nie auf
die wahre Ursache aber ich glaube dass
das macht auch machen auch nur wenige
Leute die halt würde ich sagen das muss
zum Beispiel die Impfung sein
es geht ja nicht um die Frage jetzt
schon sagen zu können was es ist bloß
wenn ich mir überlege wie wenig in den
letzten zweieinhalb Jahren Pandemie an
wissenschaftlicher Evidenz nämlich quasi
überhaupt keiner dem Staat ausgereicht
hat die schwerwiegendsten und
weitreichendsten Grundrechtseingriffe in
der Nachkriegsgeschichte Deutschlands zu
verordnen und jetzt liegt da so ein so
ein es ist ja nicht mal nicht mal mehr
der elefante im Raum steht das ist die
gesamte Elefantenherde die im Raum steht
dass da irgendwas nicht stimmen kann und
der Staat stellt sich für weiß ich
eigentlich auch nicht ja
Pizza
eindimensionale Erklärung für
offensichtlich multifaktorelle
zusammen dass man genauer hinschaut es
geht jetzt nicht darum eine Lösung zu
finden direkt an diesen Tisch das werden
wir heute schaffen aber es geht darum
genauer hinzuschauen und auch die
Stimmen zu hören
Energie während der Pandemie zu wenig
gehört wurden das wird in Teilen jetzt
auch eingestanden viele sagen ja das
gibt es das müssen wir Gede dir diese
Aufarbeitung Sebastian weit genug muss
die Politik an diesen Schrauben mal
stärker drehen sich dem Meer stellen es
wird ja gar nicht richtig aufgearbeitet
viele haben ja auch ein Interesse daran
dass eben nicht aufgearbeitet wird ich
fand es zum Beispiel sehr erschreckend
wie leicht man offensichtlich in unserem
Land rechtsstaatliche Strukturen
aushebeln kann das ist ja passiert und
vielleicht man aber auch den
Parlamentarismus aushebeln kann ja also
das nicht mehr im Parlament beschlossen
wird über solche Maßnahmen sondern das
in einer Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
diese berühmte mpk-schalte dann
irgendwie so im im Hinterzimmer und
nachts quasi irgendwie untereinander was
besprochen wird was dann aber gar nicht
demokratisch letztlich legitimiert ist
durch Politiker mit den entsprechenden
Mandaten das fand ich beides sehr
erschreckend und ich finde auch dieses
Modell dieser sogenannten
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz müsste man
sich insgesamt mal ansehen ob man davon
noch weiter Gebrauch machen will sowas
gehört eigentlich nach meiner Auffassung
ins Parlament damit Leute darüber
entscheiden die von uns auch gewählt
worden sind kann ich als also als Jurist
und und freut unserer Verfassung
eigentlich gar nicht gar nicht genug
unterstreichen und das war auch in den
letzten zweieinhalb Jahren immer wieder
ein Argument zu sagen dass viele von den
Regeln nicht mit der nötigen
demokratischen Legitimation geschlossen
worden sind wir haben ein Bundestag
einen Bundesrat eine wir haben eine
Regierung wir haben Landtage
Landesregierungen wir haben ein
Verfassungsgericht das sind alles
Verfassungsorgane die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist ein
verfassungsrechtliches Nullung die
existiert nicht die hat keinerlei
Kompetenz irgendetwas zu entscheiden und
nominell dann Entscheidungen durch
irgendwelche Regierungen durchzuwinken
nachdem hinter verschlossenen Türen wo
niemand eigentlich genau nachvollziehen
kann wer da was mit wem besprochen wurde
an den an der Bundes nicht nur an der
Bundesregierung vorbei sondern an
Bundestag vorbei haben ja eifrig
reingeleuchtet auch in dieser
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz muss man
sagen sonst müsste man wahrscheinlich
sehr viel werden noch darüber was dort
wer wie eigentlich vertreten hat wer
wollte immer weiter verschärfen der
wollte vielleicht mal lockern wer wurde
wie zurecht gewesen von wem es gibt auch
von ganz oben aus dem Kanzleramt Frau
merkten Virologen die beraten haben wo
man jetzt heute sagt na ja heute sind
wir alle schlauer da muss ich sagen
damals
gemacht werden quasi so eine Art von
einflüster
Virologe ich weiß ja nicht haben nicht
richtig abgewogen was bedeutet das z.B
für andere Krankheiten die Leute gehen
nicht zur Vorsorge wir haben es gehört
und so weiter und haben sich nur noch
auf Corona irgendwie fokussiert und
alles andere Untertisch waren lassen und
im Ergebnis die moralische Aufladung ist
ein großes Problem ja mitten durch
Familie
Onkel Heinz lässt sich nicht impfen der
ist wohl irgend so ein alu-träger der
ist nicht also da es wird auch
geimpft es gibt weiterhin beispielsweise
wir haben schon angesprochene
impfpflichte in der Bundeswehr es gibt
weiterhin und darüber haben wir hier
auch bei bildberichtet immer mehr Fälle
von Impfschäden die sagen ich habe diese
und jede wirklich gravierende
Beschwerden seitdem ist mein Leben
wirklich eingeschränkt halten sie dem
Umgang mit diesem Thema für
gerechtfertigt ich finde erstens
unverantwortlich dass man weiter impft
wo jetzt doch auch im Schäden sehen und
zwar immer mehr und dafür dass sie
anscheinend sehr sehr selten sind sind
viele Meldungen und viele Reportagen und
viele Beispiele und dahin gehen müssen
darüber Bericht man muss darüber reden
man muss die Impfung erstmal legen um zu
testen was ist überhaupt los also was
für zu den Todesfällen warum haben wir
so viele Krebs Patienten und vor allem
warum haben wir eben Schäden was ist die
Ursache dafür
auch die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
die Menschen mit Impfschäden behandeln
sollen voll sind mit Wartelisten nur die
Menschen keinen Platz finden ja ist doch
sicheren viele wissen nicht woher kommt
jetzt diese Krankheit ist eine
unterschiedlichste Ausführungen die
einen kriegen irgendwie Herpes zoster
die anderen haben Herzmuskelentzündung
andere haben dann anscheinend Turbo
Krebs und ist genau das was sie vorhin
gesagt haben einige Wissenschaftler
haben ja vor zwei drei Jahren genau vor
diesen Entwicklungen gewarnt dass man
Übersterblichkeit kommt das ist zu
Problemen führen wird weil dieser mRNA
Impfstoff einfach nicht getestet wurde
und ihn dann auf die Menschheit
loszulassen und dann auch noch mit
Steuergeldern den zu finanzieren dieses
Marketing von Pfeife und kurz zu
übernehmen
und großes Lob aus gesprochen für Bayern
Tag quasi als Retter in der Pandemie wie
kam das bei Ihnen persönlich an er nicht
gut weil das Spiel ist noch nicht zu
Ende es geht immer 90 Minuten und wir
sehen ja dass du auch pro Sekunde
lateralschäden entstanden sind auch
gesundheitlich nicht nur
gesellschaftlich und Bayern Tag macht ja
auch die Pflege wieder die
Krebsforschung Richtung England aussen
hatte zehn Milliarden verdient saßen ja
auch in Deutschland an der Goldgrube
oder lustiges Beispiel dass die eine
Goldgrube sitzen in Mainz und jetzt
gehen sie mit nachdem sie Milliarden
verdient haben und das nicht sein also
braucht man auch eine übergewinnsteuer
eigentlich bei biontek weil wir haben
den ganzen Schlamassel eigentlich
finanziert mit Steuergeld und wir haben
das Marketing gemacht es war eigentlich
in der Haftung Null genau das ist ja
auch noch der absolute Hammer da habe
ich auch dazu ein Video mal gemacht dass
er in den EU geheimverträgen hatten
geheimverträgen muss man sich mal
überlegen von der EU das da drin steht
dass die im Hersteller geschützt werden
vor allem ein feindungen von Bußgeldern
als auch für irgendwelchen Verfahren
dass die Uhr sich schützend vor diese
Konzerne stellt ich dachte immer die EU
stellt sich vor die Bürger und nicht vor
die Konzerne das heißt wenn was sein
sollte zum Beispiel im Schäden oder
Schadensersatzklagen dann zahlen wir
dafür und es ist doch ein und warum
Geheimverträge erstens das wir wissen
nicht was haben wir bezahlt ja was sind
die Abmachungen und warum muss dann die
euphor oder die ganzen moderner und so
weiter schützen und nicht die Bürger die
jetzt darunter leiden neue Verträge das
ist das Stichwort die gibt's nämlich
jetzt abzuschließen im
Wirtschaftsministerium von Robert Habeck
und Sebastian das ist ein Thema das
richtig ordentlich auf 20 Millionen Euro
sind ausgeschrieben ein super Job ich
muss sie gleich noch mal fragen ob sie
sich da bewerben aber zuerst einmal
warum regte ich das auf unserer
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
hat eine riesen Ausschreibung gerade
laufen sein Ministerium sein Haus er
will Juristen verpflichten juristische
Berater über also als externe
Dienstleister für bis zu 20 Millionen
Euro für die kommenden Jahre für
Beratungsleistungen in der Energiekrise
und er sagt dazu das müsste jetzt sein
weil die Leute in seinem Ministerium
überarbeitet sein aber es sind 2400
Mitarbeiter die er hat natürlich
zuständig für unterschiedliche Bereiche
das ist auch klar aber es ist so es sind
genau diese Mitarbeiter es sind diese
Beamten die dafür zuständig sind ähm
Verordnung auszuarbeiten Gesetze sind
Würfe auszuarbeiten und so weiter es ist
ein Ding es ist ein verpulver von
Steuergeldern das Ministerien wie seines
immer nach externer Beratung rufen und
für solche Millionenbeträge da jetzt ähm
Unterstützung haben wollen das kann
nicht sein wir Bürger müssen ständig den
Gürtel enger steinern an jeder Stelle
der Staat sollte auch tun und kann nicht
20 Millionen für sowas verpulvert sage
ich
60 Millionen stehen da außerhalb man ist
das ein reizvoller Job sie sind vom Fach
sozusagen aber was ist denn da für so
eine Berater Stunde was berechnet man
denn da so das ist ja man muss dazu
sagen das ist ja nichts Neues der der
Staat lässt sich ja in Gerichtsverfahren
schon lange von einer Handvoll größerer
Kanzleien vertreten die Namen sind auch
bekannt wer das ist und dass man da für
eine was er sich für eine partnerstunde
oder wer das macht 350 € die Stunde
bezahlt Minimum das ist auch kein
Geheimnis das ist mussten sie ja
irgendwann auf klagen genau aufdecken
weil ja freiwillig machen die das ja
nicht was ist denn ihr Stundensatz
eigentlich ähm es kommt also für den
Start würde ich wahrscheinlich genauso
viel abrufen sagen was man so
das also das ist selbst für für
Rechtsanwälte die die Stundensätze
abrechnen deutlich
überdurchschnittliches honora der
Durchschnitt liegt bei 200 20 25 Euro im
Bundesdurchschnitt wenn man nach Stunde
abrechnet und nicht nach dem
Rechtsanwaltsvergütungsgesetz von daher
das ist erstmal nichts Neues die
Dimension die das annimmt und die
Offensivität mit der das gemacht wird
weil wo kommt auf einmal diese
Überarbeitung her und der Personalmangel
bei 2400 Mitarbeitern das ist die Frage
die ich mir stelle und ich sehe da
natürlich auch wenn wenn wir schon mit
Rechtsstaatlichkeit um die Ecke kommen
es ist ein ganz massives
rechtsstaatlichkeitsproblem wenn Gesetze
Gesetzesentwürfe und solche Sachen de
facto von privaten ausgearbeitet werden
von denen wir nicht wissen von wem sie
ihr Geld sonst noch bekommt das ist auch
eine ganz einfache Rechnung wenn man so
eine große Wirtschaftskanzlei anheuert
und man soll zu energiewirtschaftlichen
Themen ein Gesetzesentwurf ausarbeiten
und die haben einer von deren Mandanten
ist zum Beispiel weiß ich ja nicht aber
kann ja sein ein großes
energiewirtschaftsunternehmen die werden
nichts unternehmen was diesem
Unternehmen Schaden zufügen wird 2014
Mitarbeiter hat er das
Wirtschaftsministerium und jetzt ist es
Argument ja man bräuchte auch mehr
Spezialisten da wird sich natürlich die
Frage auf gibt's unter den 2400
Mitarbeiter nicht genug Spezialisten
glauben Sie das sind tatsächlich so
spezielle Fragen und Fällen Fälle dass
man da unter den 2400 nicht eigene
Spezialisten hat also ich hatte das für
insofern unwahrscheinlich weil die Leute
sitzen da ja erstens direkt an der
Quelle
und man muss natürlich auch sagen wenn
da keine Spezialisten sitzen warum
werden dann keine Spezialisten
eingestellten man kann natürlich sagen
die Leute die die Spezialisten sind und
was auf dem Kasten haben die gehen nicht
und arbeiten im Ministerium bei Ihnen
das Gehalt zu gering ist also von daher
da da kommen wir vom hunderten ins
Tausendste von der von die was die
Problemlage angeht und das ist generell
muss man sagen für den Staat im ein
Problem geworden qualifizierte Juristen
in den Staatsdienst zu holen weil die
dort schlicht und ergreifen erstens
nicht mehr genug Geld verdienen und
zweitens die Arbeitsbelastung z.B auch
bei Richtern und Staatsanwältin
astronomisch geworden ist und man
Technik stand auch Deutschland keine
Unterstützung bekommen
Dienstleistung Herr Hawk so
argumentierte Wirtschaftsminister ja
auch der sagt viele in meinem Team die
können nicht mehr die müssen auch mal
schlafen die müssen auch mal essen die
haben Tinnitus die kriegen Burnout da
ist er doch eigentlich ein toller Chef
wenn er sagt so jetzt brauche ich heute
neue Leute und die Kosten eben auch was
und die muss ich jetzt einstellen also
vielleicht mal auf politischer Ebene
kann ich aus Österreich ein bisschen
erzählen dass die Erfahrung lehrt das
ist gar nicht so schlimm ist in
Deutschland ja also wir haben es glaube
ich ein bisschen mehr noch verbockt was
politikskandale an und so weiter angeht
also da vielleicht vielleicht ein
bisschen Beruhigung reinbringen von der
österreichischen Seite und natürlich die
die Frage also Burnout das ist ja
momentan Begriff der große Runden macht
ja weil die Leute natürlich massiv
überarbeitet worden sind weil sie meines
Erachtens auch in Berufen arbeiten die
für diese klassischen acht Stunden am
Tag absitzen gar nicht gebaut sind ja
also geistige Berufe wie ist der Anwalt
z.B auch ist eine ganze Menge
verschiedene Anweisung Berufe da drin
die im politischen Sektor sehr sehr oft
unterwegs sind die sind für solche
durchgehenden Arbeitsbelastung einfach
nicht gebaut also ich glaube da würde
man vielleicht allen ist ja auch mein
großes Thema Arbeitswelt von morgen
kommen wir noch zu vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr auch Flexibilität ich weiß
Flexibilität im Staat das klingt schon
quasi unmöglich vor allem
arbeitskonzepten wäre vielleicht
empfehlenswert dann brennt einem
vielleicht nicht alle sofort raus
eingestellt also hat er schon
entgegenwirkt und jetzt wieder wie wird
das auf sie ja es ist ein krebsgeschwürf
seit Jahren die Staatsquote ist schon
bei über 50%, was immer ein Zeichen
dafür ist das was nicht ganz in Ordnung
ist das ist Richtung Sozialismus geht
und wir sehen ja wie der Staat immer
mehr Menschen eigentlich de facto
einstellt immer mehr Personal braucht
also wir haben ja in der Führungsriege
seit die letzten Jahre haben es auch
gewesen eine Art ähm Fachkräftemangel ne
und jetzt sehen wir halt einfach dass
der Staat der größte Arbeitgeber ist und
es sind ja Sachen die wir bezahlen
müssen und warum muss ich dann immer
noch durch meinen eigenen Führerschein
bezahlen Steuern drin ist nicht
Steuerquote ist schon die höchste
weltweit die wir bezahlen immer neue
Abgaben das heißt wenn der Stadt immer
weiter mutiert immer mehr Mitarbeiter
einstellt die Menschen immer mehr
abhängig werden auch vom Staat werden
die an der Wahl oder natürlich immer das
gleiche Ergebnis erzielen und natürlich
auch abhängig ist entsteht eine
Abhängigkeiten ungesunde Abhängigkeit
weil ich bin mir sicher die drei vier
fünf Millionen Staatsangestellten die
werden definitiv kein Wandel initiieren
und das ist wie ich finde
brandgefährlich für uns und Demokratie
dass wir immer mehr Menschen in der
Abhängigkeit vom Staat haben immer mehr
heißt doch nicht immer besser muss man
sagen man kann auch noch 500 Leute mehr
anstellen wenn die Arbeitskonzepte
einfach mal Rode sind und die
Produktivität nicht stimmt und das ist
was mich immer interessiert wie kriegt
man mehr Produktivität raus dann kann
man noch 10.000 Leute anstellen und
besser als nichts geworden also ich
glaube da muss man mit neuen
arbeitskonzepten auch an diese doch
manchmal alten verkrusteten Strukturen
ran dann braucht man vielleicht nicht so
viele Leute die dann insgesamt
produktiver sind es gibt ja dann noch
die Abhilfe der Digitalisierung eines
Tages irgendwann mal auch in Deutschland
ich hoffe dass die künstliche
Intelligenz irgendwann von der Politik
entdeckt wird und sagt komm die können
uns zu Seite stellen oder vielleicht
sogar die Politik ersetzen ehrlich
gesagt lieber wenn die Politik erstmal
die natürliche intelligente ja gut das
kann man die an der Algorithmen aber
merkt schon dass der Berufsstand
natürlich jetzt auf einmal durch die
Neuerungen der künstlichen Intelligenz
auch zum ersten Mal bedroht ist ne also
die hochsegment Beruf wenn man sie die
sehr gut bezahlten Berufe wiegen
Werbetexter Journalisten z.B auch ja das
ist die Berufe
die bedroht sind also die Zukunft
sicherste Job momentan ist
Krankenpflegerin oder
tagesschweste für Kinder das ist
momentan der sicherste Job den man
nehmen kann verschlafen bisschen
verstaubt die falschen Strukturen du
berichtest seit Jahren auch bis dann
auch tief drinnen mit deinen Kontakten
Innenministerium wie verschlafen ist die
Arbeitswelt dort also wird es
weitergehen wenn wir das Zukunftsmodell
zeichnen das immer mehr Leute immer mehr
Personal aber man ändert an den
Strukturen nichts und dann hilft es auch
überhaupt nicht also diese Behauptungen
sehr gut abgesichert natürlich kann man
in der freien Wirtschaft erstmal mehr
verdienen aber Leute die die haben gut
Beamten Stellen am Ende eine Pension die
wirklich sehr gut ist das gibt's in der
freien Wirtschaft so nicht da muss man
klar sagen und ich kaufe ehrlicherweise
das mit der Überlastung nicht so ganz ab
natürlich sind die in der Energiekrise
jetzt besonders gefordert das zuständige
Referat hat alles andere wäre auch
völlig überraschen aber jetzt zu sagen
oh die müssen jetzt Überstunden machen
ja natürlich wenn wir Bundestagswahl
haben meine Kollegen und ich im
Politiker dann machen wir auch
Überstunden das gehört eben mit dazu das
ist man eben gefordert so ein Minister
wie ein Corona natürlich musste
besonders ran wir müssen die zuständigen
Leute besonders das ist sicherlich so es
ist aber auch ein abschieben von
Verantwortung weil man nämlich dann eben
sagt ah das hat uns jetzt McKinsey oder
irgendwer irgendwelche tollen
Wirtschaftsberater haben uns das und das
geraten und die bringen ganz tolle
flexible Modelle sind mit und deswegen
wenn die das so sagen dann machen wir
das jetzt so ne weil man selbst sich
offensichtlich teilweise auch nicht
traut an die Entscheidung zu treffen
auch das spielt er nämlich immer eine
Rolle und deswegen sollte glaube ich
dieses ganze Beratungswesen da insgesamt
zurückgefahren werden in den Ministerium
bei Verantwortung abgeschoben wird
interessantes Thema wir sprechen hier
gleich weiter über den Verlust von
Freiheitsrechten und wir sprechen auch
weiter darüber wie Unternehmen junge
Mitarbeiter überlasten und wieder
Modelle für die Zukunft aussehen können
wenn sie gerne dran wäre
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist das fast
total
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel wenn die alle
wegfallen und wir uns gegenseitig in
Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos verkaufen das
funktioniert nicht dann ist alles essen
als Freiheit würde ich sagen das muss
jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und umierungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar sein ich finde aber diese
gesamte Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch
ein bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über den Bericht
[Musik]
zurück bei viertel nach acht schön dass
Sie bei uns sind und jetzt reden wir
über das da über das Bargeld ich konnten
sie ihren Kaffee heute am Flughafen noch
bar bezahlen im Flughafen ja aber nicht
bei Eurowings an Bord weil da darf man
nur mit praktischen Karte zahlen genau
das Bargeld ist am Ende sie hängen am
Bargeld sie wollen das Bargeld weiter
haben aber Sie glauben noch viel mehr
sie glauben wir könnten lieb gewonnene
Freiheitsrechte verlieren nehmen sie uns
mit in ihr Thema sehr sehr gerne ja wir
sehen seit Jahren eigentlich de facto
ein Krieg ein Kampf gegen das Bargeld
erst wurde der 500 € Schein abgeschafft
die Gründe war natürlich der Deckmantel
war der Steuerhinterziehung Geldwäsche
und so weiter aber in Wahrheit was ganz
anderes warum weil die Imperia hat
gewissen es hat gar nichts bewirkt ganz
im Gegenteil und jetzt sehen wir die
Bargeld Obergrenze der EU parallel sehen
wir weitere Vorbereitungen dass die
digitale Bezahlung immer weiter
vorangetrieben wird die Bundesregierung
hat seit 16 Millionen Steuergelder in
die Abschaffung des Bargelds investiert
da war ich auch baff das habe ich für
meinen letzten Bestseller recherchiert
und es waren Millionen Steuergelder die
in die Bette den Cash Alliance
investiert worden sind da ist dann das
sind dann Visa oder Mastercard aber auch
die Bill Gates Stiftung und jetzt muss
ich aber kurz mein Hut aufziehen weil
wir wollen ja provokant weiter gucken
ähm es sind weg Verschwörungstheorien
aber sie wissen Verschwörungstheorien
hat in den letzten Jahren eine sehr
kurze Halbwertszeit ich glaube
tatsächlich dass das alles nur die
Vorbereitung ist das Fundament ist für
eine digitale Diktatur schön ne
ich empfange gerade ein Radiosender nee
Spaß beiseite also Fakt ist tatsächlich
wir sehen einfach dass die digitale
Diktatur vielleicht implementiert wird
warum weil wenn wir alle den digitalen
Euro haben eine digitale ezb-wolle haben
dann kann man das alles verknüpfen alle
bezahlgänge sind transparent wir sind
der gläserne Bürger die EZB kann alles
kontrollieren wenn man dann unbeliebte
Meinung hat gegen das narratives kann
man sofort bestraft werden es kann
eingefroren werden wir können natürlich
auch das CO2 Konto bekommen dass ihr nur
zwei fünf oder zehn Tonnen hat und wenn
er zu viel Fleisch ist oder mit dem
Flugzeug aus Wien kommt und so weiter
dann wird es einfach abgezogen oder der
Strafzettel kann bezahlt werden die
Rundfunkgebühren abgezogen werden es
gibt keine Möglichkeit mehr legal sein
Geld aus dem bankenkreislauf aus den
Händen der Politik zu ziehen und dann
sehen wir natürlich auch dass dann
eventuell weitere Maßnahmen unternommen
werden könnten wie z.B das ist im
Zertifikat angedockt wird an die EZB
Wallet oder auch vielleicht nach
chinesischen Vorbild kann es sein dass
wir dann alle eine Art soziales
Kreditsystem implementiert bekommen
werden gegen die Regierung ist oder sich
zum achten Mal nicht impfen lässt der
der wird dann gleich bestraft und es
wird alles eingefroren immer wieder ab
oder ich fahre jetzt auch nicht sicher
ob ich mit Ihnen oder dem autohut
spreche aber ich möchte einmal weil ich
habe Sebastian laut neben mir schnaufen
hören du glaubst wir könnten eigentlich
gut auch ohne Bargeld Leben zumindest
viele andere Länder machen ja Schritte
in diese Richtung Vorteile das hat so
ein bisschen zwei Seiten also zum einen
muss man sagen diese Entwicklung die du
da jetzt skizziert steht natürlich unser
Rechtsstaat entgegen wir haben jetzt
schon darüber gesprochen wie der auch
ausgehebelt werden kann an bestimmte
technische Möglichkeit wäre da so
einiges wir haben sogar den im
Zertifikaten gesehen was jetzt mal sehen
dass man damit zu tun
und so weiter das sind schon
interessante Punkte ich selbst liebe
Bargeld weil ich dann immer sehe was ich
ausgebe ja also so da weiß man hier 40
€, so wie schnell sind die weg wenn man
immer nur hier Karte hier da oder so mit
der Apple watch schön dran dann geht das
Geld weg und man merkt gar nicht oh was
passiert damit eigentlich deswegen bin
ich großer Fan des Bargeld die deutschen
Zahlen übrigens so gerne mit Bargeld
oder so viel Bar mit Bargeld wie kommen
andere europäische Nationen es hat
natürlich aber auch zwei Seiten weil ich
mir manchmal auch denke na ja gerade in
Berlin erlebt man ist da wird ich habe
keine Karte akzeptiert in manchen Bars
und so wo man weiß da ist möglicherweise
Geldwäsche im Hintergrund das könnte man
natürlich auch besser einigen wenn man
auf
Freiheitsentziehung hast du aber nicht
vor einer Überwachung vor allem
gläsernen Bürger das natürlich immer
mehr Informationen über dich und auch
dein Kaufverhalten und vielleicht auch
weitere Informationen dass die natürlich
irgendwo hinkommen mach dir so etwas
Angst teilst du diese Zukunftsvision wie
der Friedrich aufgezeigt hat also da ist
schon natürlich einiges möglich an
Entwicklung in dieser Hinsicht man sieht
ja selbst wenn man irgendwie so peinlich
genau dokumentiert hat da hast du 5 €
ausgegeben da bist du mit dem U-Bahn
dahin gefahren hier in dem Restaurant
und so weiter
ist schon irgendwie so ein Tagebuch der
eigenen Geldausgaben ist natürlich die
Frage wer kann da eigentlich immer so
zugreifen drauf und so weiter da wird
schon so ein digitales Stammbuch an
Freiheit ist doch das einzige zulässige
Zahlungsmittel lautet der EZB also
digitale Geld zählt eigentlich gar nicht
und ich kann dann halt auch noch
sozusagen zur Bank gehen das Geld
abheben und dann in Schließfach legen
und das Kopfkissen tragen ich kann mein
playboy-magazin kaufen ohne dass es
jemand erfährt ja also es ist wirklich
auch wichtig für die Anonymität weil
sonst ist man tatsächlich komplett
durchleuchtet und dann kann jeder
Schritt eigentlich überwacht werden wenn
ich überall nur digital bezahlen kann
eine komplette Durchleuchtung Herr Hawks
halten sie sowas für realistischen in
Zukunft als Zukunft also zum Glück haben
wir auch schon das Negativbeispiel auf
der Welt ne also China zeigt natürlich
vor wie immer wie gesagt die Verknüpfung
mit Social Credits und so weiter da ist
es vielleicht ganz hilfreich dass wir in
Deutschland mit der Digitalisierung noch
ein bisschen hinten nach sind und dann
bei uns natürlich Diskussion ob mein
kleiner sehr sehr weit hinten muss man
sagen ja also insofern ist es vielleicht
ganz gut weil dann kann man auch
beobachten und sehen was macht
vielleicht davon Sinn und was nicht also
es wird garantiert brauchen ja natürlich
gibt es diese Sorgen und das sind
natürlich auch die ganzen Hollywood
Filme dieser Welt schuld dass wir immer
Angst davon haben dass wir sagen von dem
Bösen Zentralstaat kontrolliert werden
der natürlich dann durch digitale Mittel
noch viel mehr Daten Einsicht bei uns
hat momentan machen ist halt die
privaten dann ist es halt der Start so
könnte man es jetzt zynisch sagen also
ich bin prinzipiell davon überzeugt dass
wir sowieso neue globale Spielregeln für
digitale Informationen brauchen weil der
dem Ding mit nationalstaatlichen
Mechanismen nachzulaufen das wird sich
im Ende nicht ausgehen CO2 Budget jetzt
von drei Tonnen beispielsweise da kann
man genauso etwas dann implementieren
wenn wir diesen Gedanken jetzt einmal
weiterspielen Klimawandel liegt ihnen am
Herzen wie könnte man das gedanklich
weiter spenden
würden zu einem gewissen Grad aber auch
hier bei uns nein
ich also
es ist glaube ich und das muss man noch
mal festhalten Technologie ist die
Lösung auf das Klima Problem und nicht
der Gegner und momentan befinden wir uns
in der Lage wo eben der ganze Diskurs
rund um Nachhaltigkeit immer nur mit
Verknappung Mühe Verengungen gehalten
wird und das macht einfach niemanden
Lust auf Zukunft wenn sie mal schauen
welche Wörter assoziieren die Deutschen
mit dem Begriff Nachhaltigkeit sind ist
nur negative Wörter und dieses Abbild
dass man eben ja wir müssen in die
Zukunft und dann müssen wir zurück in
die Holzhütten und dürfen nichts mehr
konsumieren das ist einfach ätzend und
wenn man kein Ziel hat dann ist die
Reise auch schwierig also ich glaube
momentan stehen mir vor der
Herausforderung dass wir den Begriff der
Nachhaltigkeit umkodieren natürlich
brauchen wir jetzt eine Zeit lang ein
Paar Verhaltensveränderung um uns Zeit
zu kaufen um diese neue Technologien zu
entwickeln aber das Ziel des
gesamtgesellschaftliche Ziel im Kontext
und Nachhaltigkeit ist eigentlich gerade
nicht da niemand hat Lust auf die
Nachhaltigkeit Zukunft die momentan
medialen auch politisch verbreitet wird
und ich glaube wenn man das dreht ja
wenn man da einen positives Bild von
Zukunft kommt das auch Lust ja also da
zu einem wunderbaren Begriff
hedonistische Nachhaltigkeit ja also im
Ende hat man so viel Ressourcen und so
viel sie wünschen sich das erst am Ende
fast Freude macht wird es aber auch
bedeuten dass sie im Umkehrschluss fast
begrüßen würden wenn es auch eine
zunehmende Überwachung gäbe so wie Herr
Friedrich sie befürchtet Überwachung man
muss das halt mit Preisen und fertig
also ich finde das bedeutet das andere
sich vielleicht nicht leisten können das
ist halt wie so oft eingangs wird es ein
Luxusproblem sein das ist einfach so und
dann kommt der Wandel ja also man sieht
immer sehr schön dass wenn man der
Trendforschung sich ganz schön anschauen
es braucht immer eine Zeit lang bis ich
solche Sachen auch mehr als fähig
durchsetzen ne das so funktioniert halt
Gesellschaft und Historien da also da
kann man kann sich das gerne anders
wünschen aber es wird nicht anders also
stehen mit so einem Schulterzucken und
sagen ist halt so kann man nichts machen
ich bin ja auf der bin ja auf der Suche
nach einem positiven Ziel ja also die
Reise dorthin die kann ist sowieso sehr
sehr schwer abzustellen ja da wird es
noch sehr sehr viele Tangenten geben die
wir noch gar nicht kommen sehen ich bin
eher auf der Suche nach dem größten
ganzeren also wirklich auf der
Zukunftsvision als Ganzes und nicht mich
immer in dem kleinteiligen zu verlieren
weil das passiert uns ja gerade im
Diskurs wir haben gesagt aber ich habe
das gesehen und deswegen funktioniert
niemals und dann ist die Zukunft tot und
dann habe ich keine Lust mehr einen
kleinen teiligen schon die Zukunft wir
werden in Zukunft digital wahrscheinlich
immer mehr bezahlen digitales Geld geben
und so weiter aber wenn es halt in die
falschen Hände gerät ja und man kann
ganz schnell passieren dass wir
vielleicht einen Umschwung passiert mir
irgendwie extrem Links oder rechte
Partei auf einmal macht haben oder
irgendwie verrückten Minister im
Gesundheitsministerium ja dann kannst du
gut sein dass es gegen die Bürger
verwendet würden da sage ich ganz
ehrlich wäre den Anfängen wir brauchen
Schutz das kann nicht sein dass die EZB
sagt wir brauchen bis 2025 den digitalen
Euro wieso denn ja also wieso soll das
Bargeld für abgeschafft werden es geht
um eine Freiheitsrechte es geht um
unsere an Mobilität dass wir auch in
Zukunft noch anonym einkaufen gehen
können und nicht ständig überwacht
werden und da kann die Technik sehr
schnell gegen uns verwendet werden und
die Gefahr sehe ich ganz klar und ich
glaube tatsächlich dass das auch
Richtung China gehen wird dass China das
große Vorbild ist das Innenministerium
hat das schon ein Bericht darüber
geschrieben dass eigentlich diese social
predit system eigentlich ganz gute
Vorteile für den Staat hätte ganz
charmant ist und damit den bei mir alle
Alarmglocken an und dann möchte ich
einfach die Bürger die Zuschauer hier
bei 8:15 Uhr einfach sensibilisieren
nicht alles zu schlucken dass man außer
Glas ist bequem mit dem Handy zu
bezahlen aber es hat auch Nachteile hat
immer einen Preis nicht umsonst ich soll
mal historisch gesehen habe ich keinen
Zweifel dass das passieren wird wenn
der das Bargeld in der Form wie wir es
kennen abgeschafft wird weil nichts aber
auch nichts was in den letzten
500 Jahren in der Menschheitsgeschichte
passiert ist lässt mich glauben dass der
Staat wenn er diese Macht auf sich
konzentriert sie nicht missbrauchen wird
die das gesamte 20 Jahrhundert ist das
perfekte Beispiel dafür was passiert
wenn der Staat diese Macht auf sich
konzentrieren kann wenn man ihm die
Möglichkeit gibt diese Macht auf sich zu
konzentrieren wird er sie missbrauchen
das 20 Jahrhundert war das tödlichste
jahrhundert in der Geschichte der
Menschheit und das ist die Lektion die
wir da rausgezogen haben wir haben es in
Kanada gesehen die trucker-proteste ich
möchte daran erinnern das waren
Vorgeschmack auf das was uns erwartet da
ist paper alles mögliche an eingefroren
wurden
wir haben es gesehen dass der Staat in
welcher Geschwindigkeit ein
Rechtsstaat wie Kanada sich selber
bezeichnet dazu nicht nur in der Lage
ist sondern willens ist aber auch
Neuseeland wir haben da gesagt gefallen
Demokratien ganz schnell umgekippt sind
und Fakt ist laut Acton hat ja mal
gesagt Macht korrumpiert absolute Macht
korrumpiert absolut und die Gefahr
besteht nun mal und wir brauchen wir
müssen Geld und Staat brennen
gerade dafür plädiert dass wir auch das
große Ganze sehen und zwar nicht Zug in
einem kleinen kleinen und in den sorgen
verlieren macht ihnen das ja nicht doch
Sorge muss man diese Sorgen nicht auch
ernst nehmen also in Betrachtung
nämlich in den verlaufen und ich will
davon nichts von der Zukunft blockiert
werden das ist das passiert sehr oft in
unseren heutigen sehr schnelligen
Diskursen und die andere Seite ist
glaube ich Deutschland der
deutschsprachige Raum hat er ein großes
historisches Trauma mit totalitären
Systemen gehabt und diese Lektion die
daraus gelehnt gelernt wurden natürlich
sehen wie diese musste immer sofort an
jeder Ecke das ist auch klar das ist
auch nur menschlich aber ich glaube
genau deswegen werden wir nicht auf so
eine chinesische Position davon
reinfallen weil die Bürger eben sehr
wohl historisch in den
Familiengeschichten einfach erlebt haben
und erzählt bekommen haben was passiert
wenn das wenn so etwas geschieht und im
Ende gehen Sie auf die Straße aber
gerade die coronazeit hat doch gezeigt
wie schnell die Menschen manipuliert
werden können wie schnell so eine
Massenpsychose entstanden ist wie die
Propaganda geglaubt wurde ohne zu
hinterfragen dass Leute die ich kein
Akademiker Anwälte Richter Apotheker auf
einmal völlig verblendet waren und kein
anderen kein anderes Argument mehr
zugelassen haben wir uns darüber
gesprochen die die Gesellschaft ist so
gespalten wie eigentlich de facto noch
nie zu unserer Lebzeiten da wurden
familienfreundschaften zerstört nur weil
meine andere Meinung hat also die die
Vermehrung Stigmatisierung von jemanden
der gegen das narrativ war jetzt auch
wieder mit Ukraine kriegt und so weiter
war noch nicht so schlimm wir müssen in
Diskus gehen da gebe ich dir absolut
Recht aber einiges kurz oder nicht mehr
zugelassen der wurde von oben verboten
möchte man ganz greifbares Beispiel
einwerfen ich bin unter anderem einer
der vielen vielen Kritiker der der
Corona waren App gewesen
und Z und der Zertifikat oder und allem
weil ich als allererstes gesagt habe
wenn dem Staat zu strafrechtlichen
Ermittlungszwecken diese Informationen
zur Verfügung stehen wird er auf sie
zugreifen Boom was oder passiert sowas
genau das genau das ist passiert genau
das was übrigens gesagt wurde was nicht
gemacht werden soll man hat uns
versprochen dass diese Daten nicht zur
Strafverfolgung benutzt werden
ich habe es ja nicht geglaubt aber die
staatsanstaatsanwaltschaften haben
angefangen die Polizei hat damit
angefangen das zu machen und das ist von
den Gerichten abgesegnet worden wie es
zu erwarten gewesen wäre es ist die
Polizei in die Bar gegangen hat gesagt
die war was weiß ich ein
Taschendiebstahl jetzt läuft draußen
noch rum können wir mal schnell gucken
die Leute die hier sich hier rein
geschrieben haben im Zuge der wegen
Corona musste man ja sein sondern
Adresse und so weiter angeben das ist
halt teilweise passiert und dann muss ja
auch jemand der da irgendwie so vom
Servicepersonal arbeitet erstmal die
Traute haben zusammen nee zeigt euch
nicht hier könnt ihr Zimmer
nein sagt kommen Sie mit dem
Durchsuchungsbeschluss und um die Ecke
und der Richter segnet das ab es gilt im
Strafprozess recht erstmal der Grundsatz
dass die Strafverfolgungsbehörden sich
aus allen legalen Quellen bedienen
dürfen zur straf Ermittlung zur
Ermittlung von von Straftaten und was
legal ist das entscheidet am Ende der
BGH ob es ein Revisionsgrund ist oder
nicht das das steht in den Sternen im
Zweifel wird wird ein Gericht immer
sagen naja eine andere Erkenntnisquelle
hatte die Staatsanwaltschaft ja nicht
und wir verfolgen eine ganz schwere
Straftat dann passt das schon sein also
dass die Botschaft die ich mitnehme aus
dieser Runde das gilt auch für das
nächste Thema jetzt mit Tristan einmal
in die Zukunft und wir schauen in die
Zukunft der Wirtschaft und wir schauen
genau darauf wie Unternehmen junge
Menschen die einen Arbeitsmarkt starten
bei der Stange halten können wie sie den
Arbeitsmarkt attraktiv machen können und
nicht die Menschen überlassen können Ihr
Thema also mich interessiert vor allem
momentan der demografische durch die
vielen durch die Krise die wir momentan
haben es brennt ja irgendwie an jeder
Ecke vergessen wir das natürlich die
Wirtschaft in Zukunft gibt und die
müssen wir uns kümmern denn die ist
relativ klar zu prognostizieren also
wenn man sich die Altersverteilung in
Deutschland oder den meisten westlichen
Ländern anschaut dann sieht man relativ
schnell wir haben ziemlich viele Leute
die jetzt langsam ins Pensionsalter
kommen wohl verdient das Blöde ist nur
wir haben wenn man so möchte überspitzt
gesagt nicht genug Nachschub also wir
haben schlicht und ergreifend nicht mehr
genug junge warme Körper um all die
Position die frei werden zu füllen und
dann müssen wir uns etwas einfallen
lassen denn der Vorteil den wir jetzt
momentan haben ist wir sind jetzt in
einem Arbeitnehmermarkt zum ersten Mal
ja also die Arbeitnehmer können jetzt
auf einmal andere Forderungen an
Unternehmen stellenweise jetzt sehr sehr
dringend gebraucht sind das ist anders
wenn man einen großen Überfluss an
Arbeitskräften hat aber es gibt noch ein
paar andere Hebel die wir bedienen
können und die finde ich vor allem sehr
spannend wir haben heute schon gehabt
das Thema Automatisierung
Digitalisierung künstliche Intelligenz
da tut sich einiges da werden viele
Berufe auch absolet werden aber auch wie
können wir mehr Frauen im Beschäftigung
bringen in Deutschland vor allem in den
europäischen Ländern ein großes Thema
also es gibt die Hebel und die müssen
wir jetzt in Bewegung bringen weil sonst
verlieren wir halt einen Attraktivität
Wirtschaftsstandort und ich glaube eine
Sache die wir doch sehr gerne mögen ist
dann erfolgreiche Wirtschaft in
Deutschland also es ist so eine Sache
die wir ganz gerne wollen welche Hebel
müssen wir also in Bewegung setzen
lassen uns einmal kurz bei der jungen
Generation bleiben werden die
überstrapaziert oder sind sie nicht
genug leistungsstark welche Generation
ihr kennt gar nicht mehr lehrjahre sind
Herrenjahre und die neue Generation sagt
ja Entschuldigung wir stellen uns
arbeiten ganz anders vor wo liegt die
Wahrheit
sie ist natürlich immer ein bisschen
komplexe die gute alte Wahrheit ist es
vor allem so dass die jüngeren
Generation sich das immer anhören müssen
also jeder egal aus welcher Generation
hier am Tisch das hat die Eltern
Generation schon mal über euch gesagt
das ist so das kann man ein bisschen die
Antike zurückverfolgen auch dieses Thema
keiner will mehr arbeiten niemand ist
mehr leistungsfähig das kann man
zurückverfolgen das wurde jedes Jahr
gedruckt seitdem es Zeitung gibt also es
ist ein Thema das kommt immer wieder es
stimmt auch nie ja was allerdings schon
stimmt ist dass ich die Arbeitswelt
langsam verändert vor allem die jüngeren
Generation komme jetzt langsam in den
Beruf Verein die doch eher digital
geprägt sind deswegen wollen wir auch
viele Unternehmen sehen und treffen sie
dann aber auf Arbeitsstrukturen die
natürlich in Deutschland sehr
industriell geprägt sind ja das ist ja
auch zu Recht so in Deutschland kann
Industrie verdammt gut das haben sich
historisch schon ein paar mal bewiesen
nun ist aber die Frage wie wandelt man
und ich glaube das ist uns allen klar
wir stehen hier von dem Umbruch
industriezeitleiter ins
Informationszeitalter von dem wir nicht
so gut als Begriff da werden wir schon
noch einen guten finden aber wir sind
gerade in Übergang und die klassischen
alten Arbeitsmodelle die sehr auf
abgesessener Zeit passiert sind und das
hat der BGH ja in also in Deutschland
oder auch in Europa natürlich bestätigt
Vertrauensarbeitszeit das war eine Zeit
lang Thema es gibt nichts man wird dafür
bezahlt wie Stunden
leistet und jüngere Generation steht
natürlich vor einer Situation wo wenn
sie den Beruf einsteigt mal zwei Drittel
aus Einkommen zu Fixkosten ausgeben muss
sich deswegen nicht wirklich etwas
zusammen sparen kann und dann die ganze
Zeit noch hören muss das liegt daran
dass du zu faul bist und nicht dass die
ökonomische Lage mittlerweile ist und
das hat natürlich zu großen Kränkungen
geführt und die spürt man jetzt ein
bisschen zwischen den Generation ich
glaube wenn wir mal ein bisschen
loslösen können von diesen klassischen
die immer nur mit abgesessener Zeit und
Kontrolle zusammenhängen und endlich
verdammt noch mal nach Leistungen gehen
ich habe ja mal gehört leistung soll
sich auch irgendwann mal lohnen dann
würde man glaube ich merken dass die
Jungen auf einmal sehr sehr
leistungsfähig und sehr motiviert sind
sie haben nur keinen Bock in einer alten
Arbeitswelt fest zu hängen und nur
sozusagen zur
kontrollbefriedigung ihrer Chefs dort zu
sein das ist glaube ich die
konfliktebene bei der wir gerade sind
wollen aber nicht sagt
ich glaube tatsächlich ist ein Wandel
ist ein Evolution auf dem Arbeitsprozess
ne also auch durch Corona hat mir auf
einmal Homeoffice hat er dann auch ganz
gut funktioniert und ich glaube
tatsächlich also man muss in Zukunft
anders arbeiten ist doch egal ob der
jetzt zu Hause sitzt beim Arbeitsplatz
oder hier bei viertel nach acht und
schreibt sein Text oder macht seine
Aufgaben ja ähm hauptsache das Ergebnis
stimmt ich würde wirklich
ergebnisorientiert belassen und wo man
arbeiten möchte ist doch völlig egal
dann müssen tatsächlich ein Wandel in
ciieren weil das alte mit der Stempeluhr
das ist vorbei keiner will kontrolliert
werden es gibt ein schönes Zitat von
Goethe der gesagt hat Vertrauen veredelt
den Menschen ewige Bevormundung Hemd
sein Reifen und es ist tatsächlich die
besten Ideen auf dem Klo ja also ja alle
Unternehmen Sebastian auch die Leute
wieder zurückgeholt aus dem Homeoffice
auch die großen IT-Riesen beispielsweise
haben gesagt kommt wieder zurück offener
hat man damit nicht so gute Erfahrungen
gemacht offenbar will man genau das was
sagt nämlich weiter den Blick darauf
haben was und wie viele Leute arbeiten
das glaube ich je nach Branche auch ganz
unterschiedlich teilweise eröffnet das
ja auch Möglichkeiten dass man sagt den
Job kann plötzlich jemand in Indien
machen ne das ist vielleicht dann auch
billiger also wird natürlich auch wieder
Arbeit ausgelagert kann auch ein Problem
sein also aber mein Handwerkern also in
Stuckateur dann Maler der kann nicht vom
Homeoffice aus arbeiten es wird niemals
funktionieren ja also dahin gehen müssen
wir schon ein bisschen gucken welche
Branche wir uns annehmen aber das ist ja
auch das schöne dass dadurch ganz klar
wird wo geht's mit Digitalisierung und
wo auch nicht also es gibt ja momentan
also für die Beispiele Installateur
Handwerker und so weiter fallen
richtiges Comeback weil sie auf einmal
sehr sehr dringend gebraucht sind man
muss auch sagen das muss man ganz
ehrlich betonen man hatte jüngeren
Generation immer gesagt du brauchst
jetzt eine gute Ausbildung weil sonst
musst du einen dieser Berufe machen und
auf einmal sind das die Berufe die aber
alle wollen ja also ja ganz oft ganz oft
gibt's halt die Zukunft ist ganz auf
deine Kombination aus dem alten was Sinn
macht und dem neuen was gut ist und das
sieht man ja auch dass sie diese Berufe
natürlich sehr sehr viel Sinn gemacht
haben und ich möchte vielleicht auch
noch gerade dieses Thema Vertrauen das
wird immer gepredigt ich bin ja viele
bei Unternehmen unterwegs sondern der
Wirtschaft und dann wird immer groß
gesagt ja ja bei uns in Unternehmen ist
Vertrauen ganz ganz wichtig Vertrauen
genau
ein kippt dann sagen die immer sofort
der vertrauen ist gut der erwachsen aber
Kontrolle ist schon noch besser also das
ist ein das ist natürlich ich nehme das
auch nicht böse die sind ja aufgewachsen
in einer Welt und sehr erfolgreich damit
gefahren in der und Industrialisierung
mit diesen arbeitskonzepten und fühlen
Sie jetzt natürlich gekränkt wenn ihre
Führungsrolle hinterfragt wird es ist ja
verständlich aber gerade Deutschland
muss mit dem großen Wohlstand den wir
haben darauf setzen dass man das jetzt
nutzt um diesen Übergang den man ja ein
bisschen verpennt hat jetzt aufzuholen
und das das ist hauptsächlich eine
filmkulturelle Frage glaube ich nicht so
sehr eine der Technologie und das
Budgets weil das Hammer in Deutschland
eigentlich aber ehrlicherweise
Vertrauensarbeitszeit schön und gut und
so weiter muss ja sagen sowas wie die 40
Stunden Woche ist schon auch eine
soziale Errungenschaften
müssen oder sowas sondern dass der
Arbeitnehmerrechte auch von der
Gewerkschaften erkämpft wurden wenn das
jetzt aufgeweicht wird für das auch
schon wieder so aber ich finde das
spricht der spricht ja nichts dagegen es
gibt ja auch Berufe die
Bereitschaftsdienste brauchen die Zeit
als Indikation haben ja aber es gibt
vermehrt Berufe die das nicht haben und
das muss man anerkennen Zeit abgesessene
Zeit ist ein super Indikator wenn man
breit über alle Berufe Flächen will aber
das funktioniert halt immer weniger ja
Berufe werden kleinteilige individueller
flexibler digitaler und das muss man
dementsprechend auch einfach anpassen
und ja für den zustimmen die
Errungenschaft von 60 auf 48 auf 40
Stunden war fantastisch und wie ist das
Papier gehört sonntags mir oder samstags
ja in vielen Berufen ist diese
Flexibilität natürlich möglich in
anderen Berufen halten wir fest geht das
überhaupt nicht da wird man weiter in
Schichten arbeiten müssen muss man da
sein muss man präsent sein und andere
Möglichkeiten gibt es da vermutlich
nicht interessante Diskussion ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei meinen
Gästen ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
bei Ihnen fürs zuschauen weil viertel
nach acht meins ist gut
[Musik]